autre mobilisation celle de plusieurs
milliers de chasseurs ce matin dans
plusieurs villes de l'hexagone notamment
à mont-de-marsan dans les landes forte
mobilisation également à amiens objectif
dénoncer les actions de la ministre de
la transition écologique barbara
compagnie avec ce député de la somme
plusieurs techniques de chasse sont
ciblés par le conseil d'état notamment
celle de la matole on retrouve sur place
à lucas léger un bien
mecha quelle est l'ambiance sur place
[Musique]
et bien une ambiance tout à fait festive
vous pouvez voir derrière moi sur ces
images on nomma sismar d'eros que tout
c'est ça les chasseurs sont venus vêtus
de leur gilet orange de chasse c'était
une demande de la fédération
un chasseur qui a organisé
une manifestation pour défendre le mode
de vie rural un mode de vie qui selon
eux est bien et mis en danger par une
certaine vision de l'écologie selon
agité par des poubelles
de personnes qui sont des journalistes
des militants des blogueurs ou des
personnalités plus connues viatique sur
les mots qu'ils emploient et qui met
donc en danger leur mode de vie ils
espèrent aussi plus de soutien de la
part d'un ministre de tutelle barbara
pompidou je vous propose d'écouter ce
qu'ils nous ont dit
non aux gros ras-le-bol au niveau de la
pression écolo au près au niveau de
pression écolo on va dire écologistes
purement est durement punis tiges nous
ce que ras-le-bol qui nous laisse vivre
quoi on est là pour défendre la ruralité
nos traditions nos valeurs et
aujourd'hui on peut plus se permettre de
laisser bafouer par des gens qui
soient nos traditions qui ne connaissent
pas nos valeurs voilà l'opinion publique
ne connaît pas nos traditions
les gens des villes connaissent mal
comment ça se passe compagne donc non
les gens se sont avec nous quand on
discute avec eux quand on leur explique
comment se passe la chasse comment se
passait là la pêche tout ce qui est du
monde rural ils savent ça comprend ce
que nous aurons au départ de cette
manifestation xavier bertrand candidat à
la présidentielle qui est venu apporter
se souciant chasseur je vous propose de
l'écouter tout de suite
la ruralité on la respecte les ruraux
les respecte cette manifestation
aujourd'hui à des chasseurs oui c'est
vrai et les pêcheurs et des agriculteurs
mais c'est tout simplement des ruraux
qui ne disent pas aux urbains comme il
doit vivre mais qui veulent tout
simplement qu'on ne leur dicte pas leur
conduite et qu'on leur laisse vivre les
traditions leurs patients ils veulent
tout simplement être respecté et
continuer à vivre de leur passion et ce
message là non seulement je le partage
non plus je le porte je les portais lors
des élections régionales continuera le
porter et je le porterai aussi au niveau
national parce que ce sont des
écologistes de bon sens la biodiversité
la préserve depuis bien longtemps ils
n'ont pas de leçons à recevoir la seule
chose c'est que on doit à la fois
s'appuyer sur eure on a mis en place
dans la région une opération qui
s'appelle hauts de france propre
respecter nettoyer la nature c'est leur
idée c'est le rider les chemins ruraux
ce que l'on fait dans la région ce que
je veux faire aussi davantage au niveau
national c'est avec les ruraux avec les
chasseurs les pêcheurs qu'on a eu cette
idée qui sont des démarches très
concrètes la préfecture de la somme a
demandé
aux usagers d'éviter le centre ville en
voiture les organisateurs attendaient
six à huit mille personnes et sur la
tribu tout alors willy schraen le
président de la fédération nationale des
chasseurs a appelé tout le monde au
calme qui n'ait aucun débordement
aujourd'hui
merci lucas léger pour ces précisions
direct donc damien où les chasseurs sont
nombreux à manifester